kind of like the first day of a new
grade I was joking I was like at the
table realize we were talking about
stops you know work related something
that's gonna just stop and say how
awesome it is to have this jobs and it
was like I said it's like better than
high school but it really is six years
and we're you know going there was sixth
season in its system and not only that
the script that you on the road for our
first episode of season six predictions
in bananas om G after all this time how
she still do this just brilliant yeah
and she is interested Jeremy like she's
into it
it's not oh this works so we're gonna do
what we do she's like what haven't we
done yet can we do that's different
where can we take this that we haven't
taken it before and that's what she's
doing out on super cyclone okay so you
said it's a little bit like high school
so can we do like some superlatives like
move your cast if it was most likely to
succeed who would that be to succeed and
the prom queen of course yes she would
insist on it
who's the class clowns Josh Malina okay
really interesting all right well it
might be Jeff Perry but josh is the
classic they're like the one who's
always whatever comes out his mouth it's
funny and a Serb Erica yeah best dresses
um best-dressed whoa
Cornelius Paulo and that's a good one no
time soon and most likely to have a
police record after graduation
if music you can't say you eat I got a
spare key for something nonviolent and
something that eventually have been
realized